[Music]
so many people reach out to me now and
they are full of fear about taking the
next step but I could speak from my own
experience I did it I lived it I stepped
out of the thing I went through my fear
so I can help that person who was
thinking about the next step where
they're worried about that or I can tell
they don't have saying they're full up
here and I'll let them know you're full
of fear and if you really truly want to
create your future you have to embrace
that move through it take a step of
faith a leap of faith sometimes to
create the life that you want and if
you're not willing to do that if you're
not able to do that then I don't believe
the universe God whatever you want to
call it will get behind you to create
what you need to create I believe God
will move heaven and earth when you're
on the path and you're willing to take
that leap of faith to go do what you're
meant to do that's John Gordon this week
on the referral podcast
[Music]
the wrist roll podcast hey everybody my
name is rich roll I am your host welcome
or welcome back to the show where each
and every week for the last almost five
years I have visited you weekly with
long-form at times intense sometimes
emotional deep dives with some of the
world's most interesting most
influential compelling thought leaders
personalities paradigm breakers across
all categories of health and wellness
fitness nutrition entrepreneurship
entertainment spirituality mindfulness
and in the case of today's guest Jon
Gordon leadership jon is a really great
guy this is a very special very cool
conversation but before I get into it
I'm not sure if you noticed but we
actually filmed the last podcast the
coach's corner with Chris al Caroline
Buerkle it's up on YouTube if you missed
it I'll put a link in the show notes up
to that definitely check it out it's no
biggie
it's hardly cupric Ian in its aesthetic
it's just a single locked off wide shot
a two shot but it was cool to finally do
this it was actually thrilling and from
what I can gather from all the comments
people are really diggin it and wanting
me to do more of this and I would love
to do that there's something really
special about being able to see the
dynamic unfold it's not for everyone not
everybody wants to enjoy the podcast on
YouTube but there are a lot of people
out there that get most of their content
on YouTube so it would be really great
to serve the audience in this way but
here's the thing in order to make this
happen I really need help I'm just too
busy to do all this myself for this
video we had a photographer with us up
in Tahoe
Tomas Chaco Bosque that's how I say
Jakubowski and then I said X the hard
drive to my friend Reece Robinson on the
East Coast and he did the edit and it
was fine it's great in fact but in order
to really make this work make this thing
and do this right for the future and for
going forward I need like a studio
manager I need somebody who can help
configure build-out set up this studio
space that I have into a proper
professional multimedia studio for
filming not just the podcast but a wide
array of video
objects that I would like to execute on
everything from vlogging to
instructional stuff to motivational
stuff
and I need somebody who is not just
proficient but a really talented
videographer shooter somebody who really
knows their way around the camera lenses
lighting maybe you even have your own
equipment it's not a must but it would
be good wizard at editing graphics
motion graphics Photoshop someone who
appreciates and understands great design
and aesthetics somebody who isn't going
to just do what I asked but who has the
talent and the creativity and the work
ethic and the desire to really own the
position and the responsibilities who
doesn't need to be micromanaged and can
really help elevate my work and the
messages that I'm trying to put out into
the world also and this is super
important I need somebody who is local I
really don't want to do this remotely at
this point I'm not sure if it's a
full-time job but it's pretty close
I can definitely put this person to work
pretty much every day and the key thing
is that they need to be able to be with
me on-site in person I don't know at
least three or four days a week maybe
even more so if this is you or you know
somebody who might be a good fit for
this position I would love to hear from
you so here's what you do send an email
to info at which role comm with all your
relevant experience demo reel whatever
and I look forward to checking it out
great I'm really excited about this
because I really do want to step into
the video space but I want to do it
properly correctly and with the right
partner in crime all right
Shaun Gordon like I said great guy great
this is a very fun and engaging
conversation so who is John John is a
prolific keynote speaker a best-selling
author he's a Cornell grad we actually
found out that we were there at the same
time and he's got a master's in teaching
from Emory this is a guy who has
inspired millions of readers and
audiences around the world with highly
instructive teachings on the themes of
leadership human potential teamwork and
positivity principles that have been
very beneficial to many a fortune 500
company including GE well
Agro State Farm Campbell Soup Dell
public Southwest Airlines as well as a
litany of professional and collegiate
sports teams including the LA Dodgers
the Atlanta Falcons the LA Clippers
Miami Heat
Pittsburgh Pirates Clemson football on
and on and on John also impacts
thousands of teachers and students each
year through his work with schools
universities like West Point hospitals
and nonprofit organizations he has been
featured on The Today Show CNN CNBC the
Golf Channel Fox & Friends in numerous
magazines and newspapers like the Wall
Street Journal in the New York Times and
he is the author of an astounding 17
books which is insane including 5
bestsellers the energy bus the carpenter
training camp you win in a locker room
first and the power of positive
leadership so this is a conversation
about John's path from successful deeply
unfulfilled businessperson he had a
previous career before he did what he
does now to eventually figuring out how
to live history with his bliss as an
author and a speaker it's about how he
cultivates nurtures and practices the
prolific creativity required to write 17
books it's about the core leadership and
teamwork principles he teaches that have
positively impacted the NFL the NBA all
these college coaches and teams and
fortune 500 companies and school
districts and hospitals and nonprofits
on and on and on it's about the primacy
of positivity how to confront negativity
what he calls energy vampires and
convert it or them to positivity it's
about commitment it's about service it's
about giving back and it's about the
importance of culture within an
organization who are we and what do we
stand for and it's also about the
journey to discovering what motivates
you what is your why you know we don't
get burnt out because of what we do we
get burned out because we forgot why
we're doing it you get that it's really
cool right it's cool idea alright
so buckle up
almost talked to John all right John
Gordon in the house great to be here
long time coming so awesome to be
sitting down with you thank you for
opening up your the Santa Monica annex
that gladden family except domicile so
that we could have this conversation I
it's funny as I was driving over here
when I write when I got out of rehab my
first apartment was literally like two
blocks from here so back in my old hood
but welcome to LA now what do you guys
doing down here great to be here
well we always loved LA we'd come to
visit and we would stay in this area uh
a hotel would come for a week at a time
to escape the Florida heat yeah and then
spending more time here we just said you
know we just love it here I'd be great
to come and spend more time here so then
we ultimately said I let's start looking
for a place and we found the place you
know a small condo that we could spend
time together here so we were here for
about a month so far right spend another
couple weeks and then we'll go back to
Florida that's great so yeah you have
two kids you have a daughter who's in
turning over at UCLA this summer right
she's interning there my son is a tennis
player so escape the Florida he play a
little tennis playing matches out here
hitting with some college guys having a
great experience what's it like to be
your kid should they feel the heat they
have to be you know high-performing
athletes I got word I think you know
what I I do encourage them a lot there
is an expectation of just giving our
best but really don't focus on the
outcome a lot uh-huh but I do think it's
probably something they feel you know
they know I speak to these teams they
know I work with all these organizations
my daughter went to Clemson because I
worked with Clemson football for the
past five years right she would always
come up with me to games sitting down
low Sweeney's office you know here is
talk about excellence and teamwork and
building a great team so I think they're
naturally you know used to it
it's ingrained in them uh-huh but I
don't want them to feel pressure but
they feel enough pressure on their own
yeah yeah I mean what if what if one of
them said you know I don't like sports
my daughter was a lacrosse player and
was recruited to play lacrosse right and
you're highborn and I pleaded across in
college
so I wanted her to play lacrosse uh-huh
I mean I have to admit I wanted to play
and she loved it she got good at it was
recruited by some colleges ultimately
she said I don't want to play in college
dad yeah it was hard and I said what I
said what do you mean yeah I'm glad pee
on us I said pay for your own college
that Nam's kidding I know I said you
don't want I want you to go you want to
go go to a school that you want to go to
where if you were injured and you
couldn't play you would still want to be
at that school uh-huh don't go to a
school just lacrosse she almost went to
USC mm-hmm and didn't play well in a
tournament coach stopped recruiting her
so it was a blessing in many ways
because she ultimately didn't want to
play so we had a conversation halfway
through her freshman year at college
gave missile crushing she was not at all
that now I said whether than you made
the right decision
yeah good well that's that's good
parenting yeah I got well it's it's cool
to talk to you you know we've got a
bunch of mutual friends and colleagues I
think you first came across my radar on
your the first time you're on Michael
Gervaise podcast and I just love Michael
I think he's fast the best and I think
Ryan holiday is the one that introduced
us and I know you went did you go
surfing with Rob Bell I did I was gonna
take a friend just asked it was me Rob
uh-huh in the water on our boards and
he's a good surfer so the way we just
like ever he did the wave would come in
like I John I'm gonna take this one in
he'd go in I wait for him to come back
we'd have a great conversation for a
little bit another way we come I'm
taking this money and I didn't try to
serve as much I was more kind of work on
my paddling uh-huh sitting up on a board
I mean this was my first time you sir
are useful you don't surf in Florida no
this is my first time surfing with Rob
Bell so my wife said why would you for
the first time surfing ever try to be
with Rob though for the first time never
met him before in person
uh-huh and do that said that's exactly
why you would do it that's the best way
to get to know somebody right I mean
something different something ludicrous
every what a great story to tell that
you know Rob Bell actually was very
instrumental in my spiritual journey
me years ago never meant but I listened
to a sermon he gave about Jesus as a
Jewish rabbi and I grew up Jewish right
and so it was really some that resonated
with me so I have fouled him ever since
and I saw that he was surfing and it was
one of the reasons why I was inspired to
start surfing I have two other good
friends Michael Gervais yogig Tom surfer
yogi Ross big master yeah yeah and ret
use great guy great surfer and so yogi
and and Brett took me out yesterday and
Michael and I going to go out sometime
this week or next to go surfing so he's
a Shriner yeah he's totally unbelievable
so for me it's like la something
different take on a new challenge in 46
you know don't be stale embrace the
process of what surfing will require and
do something unique in different so it
was really cool story to to just go out
with Rob and have that experience with
huh yeah he had a great conversation
till I mean we just talked about life
and and spirituality and just the
journey and it was just great so it was
like spirituality and served thing being
in that moment with nature it was
incredible well your spiritual journey
it's definitely you know one of the main
things that I want to unpack and get
into get into with you upgrade I think
it's really understand no but before I
do that I kind of want to step it back a
little bit I mean you just said you're
46 I'm 50
you played lacrosse at Cornell I went to
law school Cornell so what years were
you there I think we were there at the
same time I was there 89 92 93
okay so yeah we had a little overlap I
graduated law school of 94
oh wow so we were there for two two
years again two years at the same time
we had the pop together I don't know
like here's the thing like my universe
when I was in law school involved being
in the law school building which was
like the shining you know yes out there
and then making the pilgrimage to rule
offs that was about it or the poems but
I lived out on two Ganic on the in a
tiny little cabin on the lake
la close to the pines you know the pond
yeah so was the pines and brew law you
know it's like basically I lived in brew
laughs that's a choice you don't know
yeah
ever went in there I made the rule a
belieber up shoulders but I was out of
my mind like I still don't know how I
graduated I know about I wasn't used to
drinker but we go to rule offs a lot and
you're like is that any horner probably
we if there was a conversation that was
it
I did pass out once on a bus and maybe
we're on the same bus yeah maybe I woke
up on the side of a road by my dorm I
mean it was the only time that I ever
had that kind of experience where I
drank too much in college and it was not
good kids do not do this at home but it
was it was scary when I woke up the next
morning and I don't remember a thing
well I have more than my fair share of
those kinds of stories but took me a
little while to figure it but I think
you know just sort of speaking to your
experience as a lacrosse player I
thought a kind of cool like sort of
launchpad into the subject matter that
that I'd like to cover with you today
can sort of be encapsulated in that
hardhat story that you tell I love that
story
can you just recount that sure well
having played it at Cornell lacrosse and
graduating in 93 there was a guy who
played 11 years after I did and his name
was George Boyardee
Cornell lacrosse was not a powerhouse
when I was there towards the end before
I got there a powerhouse then we sort of
had some down years and I was there and
they became a powerhouse again after
George played at Cornell George was
selected to carry the hard hat as a
freshman the new coaches who took over
the program they picked ramallah
Jeff Tim brownie they gave a hard hat to
the hardest-working most selfless loyal
freshman on the team George was selected
to care that hard head because he
embodied those characteristics so as a
freshman he carried it now as a senior
he's a captain of the team and George
was just an incredible human being very
selfless served his team he was always
the last guy to leave the locker room
because he would always clean up after
everyone left he would clean up and then
he would give freshmen ride home back to
their dorms back to North Campus because
was a far walk and very cold as you
remember in Ithaca and these young girls
would need to drive home so he would
drive him home and encourage them and so
he was this kind of guy that was Oh
therefore his team always there to help
him and he graduated his plan was to go
to Teach for America in Sioux Falls
South Dakota on the Pine Ridge
Reservation and helped the poorest of
the poor to help people who had nothing
this was a kid who came from a very
privileged background his
great-grandfather was Chef Boyardee
so what already Chef Boyardee so but he
drove a beat-up Jeep were a hoodie
everyday the same clothes you would have
never known that he was a kid from a
privileged background because he never
wanted any of the trappings he was not
that kind of person was a very
blue-collar kind of kid and so here was
the kid was going to sacrifice and after
college go help that well senior early
in the season they're playing Binghamton
and Jorge jumps in front of a shot and
he gets hit in the chest with the ball
and he dies on the field unbelievable I
didn't know that that happened got a
that can't have not often that doesn't
happen that on and 22 years old him the
chest dies on the field the trainer that
went out to save him was my trainer Jim
case and he just said it was obviously
the most painful challenging moment of
his life his parents weren't at the game
they'd been to every game and for some
reason they weren't mad backing so as a
team after George's death they were
obviously young men devastated traumatic
experience they were deciding whether
they should play the season or not and
they got together and they decided you
know what we're going to play we're not
going to give up on the season we're
going to play but we're not going to
play to win for George we're going to
play to honor him we're going to play to
play the way he would play and to honor
his memory and from that moment on they
became like this unbelievable team that
just played with such selflessness with
sacrifice and service for of each other
with the love for each other
hard working going after the ground
balls do whatever it take to to help
your team win it wasn't about yourself
Chris - it was never been up cell phones
about others they actually had a um
something called boyardee stats which
were just like ground ball
all hustle points it wasn't about
scoring or assists it was about all
these intangible things that were worthy
stats they called show Caulfield Boyer
George's house became George's house Wow
a fictional call taught to this data to
this day and they kept his locker the
same it's still there like all his stuff
is still in his locker so his locker you
you walk in that locker room and you see
George's locker there to this day
they became this powerhouse program
after that so you have this guy who sort
of exudes the ideals of the optimal
teammate right he's got sportsmanship
he's got the work ethic he has that you
know sort of spirit the ability
transcends his own personality and and
when you see that in recounting that
story and seeing the result of his
legacy and the long-term impact on the
team and its success and the sort of
unity that that inspired like what are
the like pillars or wisdom that you
extract from that well one thing it's
really important to notice is that these
men who are his teammates and they were
young men then these men now around 32
33 34 years old they still live their
lives based on him they live their lives
- based on the kind of teammate and the
kind of person he was and they're asking
themselves every day would George be
proud of me with George be doing this
and that they literally are living in
their lives and they asked themselves
all the time that question I was blown
away interviewing these guys it just
shows the impact of this 22 year old had
even when he was 19 but I had this
impact on these men so what can we
extrapolate well one it's never about
yourself it's always about others
because George always wanted to play for
his team and make his team better he
never wanted recognition so for what I
think it's about to be a great teammate
we're so focused on ourselves in today's
culture that truly being a great
teammate is not about May it's not
pointing to yourself after your score
it's not being either the superstar on
ESPN it's about helping others and being
someone who is there for your team and
helping your team get better so I think
one that's a big part of being a great
teammate yeah I think also
you know making ensuring that that
legacy remains relevant I think takes
work and a forethought on behalf of the
coaching staff and you know the players
themselves I mean you know as you were
counting on I'm sort of thinking back
when I swam Stanford in the late 80s we
had art we had our version of that it
was the red sweat pants and it was
started by this guy Jim Reynolds
we called him Milken Jimmy and he just
was everything that you wanted your
teammate to be you know what I mean he
wasn't the fastest he wasn't the most
talented but he was all about team and
he was there for every member of the
team and he was sort of his symbol of
unity and team and ship and all that
sort of thing and this guy like every
single day he would wear the same red
carpet every day and so when he
graduated a tradition started where
those were passed on each year to the
person who who sort of embodied those
ideals and I think like the third or
fourth year I was lucky enough to wear
those sweatpants probably the greatest
honor in my sporting career because I
was like a benchwarmer favorite and then
it lived on for many years but at some
point it kind of fell away right like
there was a there was a change in the
coaching regime it said I don't know
exactly what happened as I wasn't there
but but also you know the program went
from being NC to a division one
champions every year to now fighting for
a third or fourth or fifth or six and
our coach at the time was a very flawed
individual and I have a lot of issues
when this coaching spell but one thing
that he did that I think was really
laudable was that he understood that our
success was directly related to the
extent to which the teams unified and
that that unification process began from
the top down not just with his example
as a coach but with the the leaders on
the team and that they had to shoulder
that responsibility that it couldn't
just be all on the coach and with that
would come a cohesion that would
transfer into the you know the team
operating as a unit a little bit
different in swimming because it's sort
of an individual sport but it's also a
teams for you do have to work together
but it's about individual performances
but I think the principle remains the
same yeah it said of focusing on me we
focus on weight and even with individual
sports I work with a lot of golf teams
individually focus some swim teams there
have to be this mindset of yes I want to
be my best for me but I also want to
help my team be their best and when
someone else is swimming my attitudes
contagious
my energy is contagious so if I'm
encouraging my teammate if I'm
challenging my teammate if I'm pushing
my teammate if I'm doing everything I
can to help that person get better you
know what happens in the process I get
better right and so that's the great
thing about the way this works is the
more you actually give to your teammates
and help them become the best they can
be you actually grow and improve as well
you heard her swen nater right this one
native story no I don't know that when
ADA was recruited by John Wooden to play
at UCLA he was 610 played at Cyprus
Community College and John said hey I
want you to come here to play at UCLA
but if you come here you're not going to
play that much because we have the best
center in the world and Bill wall but
yeah I do know this story but keep going
on yeah we want you to make Bill Walton
better so will you do that
so swen nater goes to UCLA and every day
in practice he's pushing Bill Walton to
get better he doesn't play much but he's
battling Bill Walton practice that's his
job he's the only person NBA history
never to have started college game but
be drafting the first round of the NBA
12-year NBA career Rookie of the Year
yeah cos he's sharpening his tool every
single day against the best in the
business and he's making Bill long
better but he gets better in the process
right you have a long term view though
you doing and that's tough for an
athlete you know that's got that takes a
lot of self-discipline
it does and I think it takes a sacrifice
of your ego to say yeah I'm going to
give up my ego see I believe everyone
should want to be great we all want to
be great you have to have an ego to want
to be great but I think ultimately have
to give up your ego serve others in
order to be great right you can you can
you can even do that selfishly right I'm
going to selfishly relinquish my ego
because it's in my best interest right I
don't know yeah it's like takes a little
mental hijinx I think but uh yeah all
right so you work with all these I mean
the number of teams and athletes
you've worked with is insane like all
these incredible collegiate and
professional programs NFL NBA and you
know you're wearing a Dodgers t-shirt
the Dodgers so when you go like when you
go into these teams I assume they invite
you in and then you go in like what's
the deal like what are you telling them
are you sitting down and like how does
it work so usually the coach will read
one of my books and that's why they
regenerate Dave Roberts with the Dodgers
I never met Dave but he read my book you
win in the locker room at first that I
wrote with Mike Smith and it's the seven
C's to build a winning team so when Mike
and I wrote this book I had no idea that
like a lot of coaches we're going to
read it and want to then do more with it
but Dave read it and reached out called
one of my team members and they started
talking and she can't want to have him
at spring training he could stay with me
and so I go after I stayed with dated
Dave's place spring training I go and
speak to the team but beforehand I met
with David his office and we just talked
we talked leadership we talked
challenges we talked some of the C's and
we just talked principles a couple
coaches will come in I'll meet the
coaches will talk and then I go speak to
the team and Dave and I already talked
about okay let's talk about the 70s
let's talk about how to build a
connected team you just talked about
cohesion earlier how can we be more
connected how could they be more
cohesive to stay strong as a team
throughout the season and that was my
talk the seven C's to build a winning
team to the team but each team is
different
might be energy bus or it might be
training camp or the power positive
leadership recently coaches or me to
speak on that so it's usually some set
of principles and I'll pick three to
five I'll talk about with the team but
it's things that I want to stick you
know it's not just a motivational talked
or rah rah do you do like a forensic
analysis of what's functioning well and
what's not functioning well and the team
like a consultant would do at a business
and say here's what's not working and
here's where I can like laser on and
perhaps provide some ability a lot of
times I'm speaking at spring training or
training kit and training camp speaking
of spring training or training camp so
it's always it to be getting usually and
usually it's a new season a new team
different dynamic now
the coach will talk about what's
happened in the past or what they're
struggling with or what messages we want
to get across so I don't really do a lot
of forensic analysis like that but it's
more like okay what are your struggles
what are your challenges and what are
the same what are some of the core
messages that we need to talk about
right like with the Dodgers it was like
okay in years past you would get to this
level you get to the playoffs but you
wouldn't push through to the next round
why they had the talent but team beats
talent when talent isn't a team right
and you you you would have I would
imagine you have a a receptive audience
in the coach that invites you like this
guy wants you you know he wants to hear
what you have to say I would imagine
that's not always the case at the
players like the coach comes in
introduces you and they're like probably
sometimes they're stoked and other times
they're like who's this guy like why do
I have to listen to him and and I think
it's I would imagine that it's at I'm
too tough audience because you mentioned
ego earlier it's like these these guys
are the best there is
right they got big egos vulnerability or
being open or talking about your
weaknesses especially in front of the
coaching staff and your teammates when a
lot of these guys are just you know they
just want to make sure they're not
getting cut right like where they going
to be doing next week and next month
that's a challenge it's one of the
biggest challenges there is in the world
of speaking Rob Bell and I were talking
about that because he's spoken to some
you know sports teams as well at the NFL
level hardest audience you'll ever find
now you have this coach that invites you
you just nailed on the head but there
are some guys are they're like okay
another talk who's here talking today
what is he talking about
but my job is to provide value my job is
to say something that can help them be
better that can that can make them
better they may not like three or four
things but maybe they'll just like one
thing that I say and that's my goal is
that if I could just say one thing that
gets your attention and will help them
get to the next level coaches always
tell me John if you can't provide value
to these guys they're going to tune you
out and that goes for coaching a lot of
coaches better know their stuff because
there's a coach if you can't help the
player improve they're not going to
listen to you then don't waste your time
because they're the best and they want
to get better so my thing is what can I
do to help them get better I spoke to
the Oklahoma City Thunder this year and
the Miami Heat
right NBA only 10 to 12 guys in a room
that was even harder than an NFL team
with his 52 7 can read everyone's facial
no problems in there I'm looking there
right there
I mean they're right there and Pat Riley
sat in on my talk as well which was
really intimidating to me
yeah tomorrow they're right there and
you're looking at them so my thing is
what I what I did for spring training
this year was three keys to having a
great season like these are the three
keys that I have found over the years
will help you have a great season if you
do these three things which are one one
was we stay positive because everyone's
positive in spring training or training
camp you're undefeated but how will we
stay positive when we face adversity and
challenges how we stay positive as a
team and optimistic believing that our
best days are ahead of us even though we
may have just had some losses even
though we just had some challenges very
prophetic with the heat they had a
horrible first half of the season but
they stayed positive next one stay
connected
gotta stay connected as a team teams
start to break down the course of the
season you can see who's given up who
doesn't really care about their
teammates who's basically already
thinking about next season their
contract and not really bought into the
team they're not engaged they're not all
in so staying connected is key and then
the third one is stay the course grit we
don't create outside and we create
inside out the power inside out versus
outside and don't look at the outside
don't look at media don't look at the
noise just focus on what you can do each
day to be your best and knowing that you
create inside out you're the ultimate
inside-out right athlete but we're not
your front so what you've created on the
outside is everything that you've done
on the inside yeah I mean that's that's
the key to long-term success you know
it's it's much harder work and you know
sometimes you got to be in enough pain
to go that route because it's much more
convenient to go from the outside in
and that kind of brings you to the next
you can serve line of questioning which
is you're a very positive guy I know you
you've evolved into that it hasn't
always been that person but when you're
talking about positivity talking about
grit talking about leadership like these
are characteristics that in certain
people are just baked in right and you
can get up in front of a group of people
and try to inspire them or incite them
but ultimately you know how do you
traverse that bridge from inspiration or
incitement into actual action and even
beyond that into you know lasting
persistent consistent action that really
is going to be the difference maker in
terms of how season is going to go yeah
I think there are those players that
tune you out and could care less that
you're there but then there are those
that come up to you afterwards and say I
needed to hear that
thank you and then there are some that
said hey can I keep in touch with you
and they give you their their cell
number and I give them mine and we stay
in touch and there have been a few and
it's really cool when when they call
you're laying in bed one night and yes
you get it out you get at em and I can't
say who they are but I've reached out to
have talked to them and encouraged them
and you take inspiration and you move
into principle you move into embodiment
you move into living it and breathing it
and you start to see the impact it has
one of most important things that you
can do it it may sound simple but it's
not it's not complicated if an athlete
could stay positive and deal with their
adversity and deal with their pain and
their negativity and really work through
that but stay positive and optimistic
and not get caught up in the rut and all
the stuff that's coming their way
that's 90 percent of the challenge they
face mm-hmm that's a big part of what I
help them do and talking to them and
encouraging them along the way it's that
simple I think that these ideas which
are really kind of mindsets are actually
their actions their practices you know
whether it's gratitude positivity
no they're just saying in in recovery
like act as if you know like fake it
till you make it like if you're if
you're somebody who's
not easily you know sort of prone to
being in an optimistic positive mindset
if you start sort of acting that way
even though me that's not how you feel
is it your opinion that you can then
sort of foster that in yourself or what
is the how do you Traverse from being
you know sort of a gloomy person into
somebody who's more positive and
optimistic well they've done studies
where actually people who maybe more
naturally negative and they try to put
on a fake smile those people kind of put
a fake smile actually are producing
stress what make it make it worse that
makes it worse I believe it always comes
from the heart it has to come from the
head you can't do because the book says
so you got to care right and that's a
cornerstone thing and that kind of
infuses all of your books yeah and your
teachings but like how do you get some
like first you got to care and then
everything kind of flows from there is
that an accurate kind of yeah like how
do you get somebody to care like if that
guy's stonewalling you right you know
there's only so much you can do that
person is not going to change that
person is that going to prove their life
but I don't know if it's fake it to you
make it
I know that as we strive to be a more
positive person and we truly start to
live it and act upon it we start to see
that fruit in our lives for me it was
taking walks of gratitude every day so
taking over thank you walk so while
you're walking you just say what you're
thankful for because you can't be
stressed and thankful at the same time I
was celebrating my successes every night
so instead of a gratitude journal at a
success journal I what was the one great
thing that happened that day so focusing
on these little positive things from
from action but going back we know that
energy creates matter energy always
creates matter it always must be an
energetic thing before it's a physical
thing so that guy's a lot of my thinking
so I always believe that it must come
from spirit or consciousness before it's
manifested in the physical reality side
outside it's the inside out it's also
again spirit creates the physical
reality so a lot of times this is shift
in perspective we're shifting people's
perspective from what they believe is
possible to know what they know as
possible or from negative to positive
and you know we're putting words to
things that it's hard to really condense
quantifiable AdWords to but it's really
this perspective of my best days are
behind me they're ahead of me it's a
perspective of moving from faith instead
of fear a perspective that says oh
that's not a challenge that's an
opportunity by what you do you've said
you know what they say it's impossible
no I believe it's possible and somehow
I'm going to do it and so we're always
defining the possible Steve Jobs did in
this in the in the you know business
world of what was possible that other
people said was impossible so for me
it's about shifting their perspective
which is a mindset but it's also a hard
thing and then it's also if you can get
someone to focus on love instead of fear
they'll perform at a higher level if
they start loving the work they do
loving playing loving their teammates
they're gonna perform at a higher level
so instead of fear we we bring forth
love yeah I like that and I think kind
of behind that you know behind the
curtain of that beneath another layer of
that is you know is honesty right like
there has to be a level of self honesty
there has to be a willingness to you
know wrestle with yourself and be
objective with who you are when you're
looking in the mirror and in the middle
of the night and that requires a certain
amount of courage also I think it goes
back to you know thing I mentioned
earlier where where you have like you
know these these alpha male athletes
best in the business like that
vulnerability is is tough to to get to
right like I believe that that
vulnerability is the is sort of
embracing that that vulnerability and
getting comfortable with it is the path
to ultimate success I think that felt
launchpad but it's got to be tough to
get those guys to that place right it is
I've noticed that you're asking earlier
about the teams in their receptivity the
teams that have read my books first
before I get there are the most
receptive right because they've
experienced yeah I've written so that
touches their heart hopefully Martin and
training-camp
very vulnerable energy bus George and
joy is the mother that they really can't
seem to connect with she's got this big
energy and great personality but she's
sharing this love and she's taking
George on a on a ride to help him change
life so I think the more they've read
the stories I get this great connection
with them when they've read the books
yeah and there's they are stories
they're stories I mean you've done
something very unique in in publishing
in that you know most of your books are
these allegories which is not something
a lot of people are doing there there
are modern-day staples
where you're really taking the reader on
this hero's journey where they can
emotionally connect with the
protagonists and really you know
understand the struggle and the payoff
at the end actually pretty like
seventeen books use like you're five
years younger than me man is like how
did you do that it's crazy like the
prolific output is unbelievable like
you're just channeling some kind of you
know ethereal source matter right to
that page that's really it I mean it's
like every book I write takes about
three and a half weeks to read crazy and
I that's asked my wife you just go into
the hole and she calls it my mad
scientist stage so it's always around
December early to mid-december and I
start writing I have the vision of what
I'm going to write so the framework but
that's it and the vision comes from
where spiritual just comes like I just
have a vision of what I'm supposed to
write for me I'm stripe a rata 2d I say
yeah the box and a lot of times of the
walks walking on the beach walking on
the street and literally I'll get an
idea almost always are on you know on
those walks but like one book I haven't
written yet I had that vision nine years
ago haven't written it yet but I have
this vision for this book it's going to
be like just crazy but I've had a vision
for it and I'm just waiting to write it
so I've had a vision before I write it
so then I sit down and I have to start
that's always the hardest part is just
to sit down and actually start writing
the book probably have to go out and
train maybe the first miles or even the
hardest so it's getting started and then
after I get started then it just starts
to flow and once the character starts
speaking to have a voice then it starts
to write itself right when I was the
carpenter I have two beginning which
came to me on a walk but
the end and I didn't know what the end
was going to be and I even called my
publisher I don't have an ending and I
we went through a couple of like how
maybe that will work maybe alone walking
to the beach one day Drolma came to me
to see how the beginning in the end
connected and both came to be on these
walks I knew it was it for me yeah you
got to open the channel right you're the
conduit for this and and and you know
that's a I would imagine a meditative
practice for you right I would say
writing is probably the most spiritual
experience that I'm having what I'm
writing a book it's the most painful at
times but just sitting down and writing
and and really being open to what's
coming through yeah it's really powerful
I always say I'm not the author I'm just
depend and I'm just here writing when
I'm meant to write and I don't want to
quit I give a lot of charity a lot of
lot of the royalties to charity because
I feel like I should and I need to
because I can't take it all I need to
give it away because it's a gift but you
didn't graduate from Cornell and to
start writing down I think but let's
step it back because the the origin
stories is fascinating and I think it
dovetails nicely into in a cut of this
you know spiritual Odyssey that you've
been on so you graduate from Cornell
you're this lacrosse player and were you
in the hotel management school that was
actually a government government
economic unit ecology uh-huh but you
went into the restaurant business at
play for uh-huh
so I went to Atlanta just drove down
there with a friend from high school
just randomly just went down there I
think to meet my wife because my wife
there but was walking around Buckhead
and met a guy outside who was the owner
of a new bar that just opened in
Buckhead and I asked him if I can have a
bartending job I was just bold enough to
ask he said have you brought him before
I said yes I have I never bartended so
they gave me a shot started bartending
there while I was getting my master's in
teaching and Emory so I'm bartending
stayed up til 6:00 at night go to school
the next day to you know go to teach and
get my master's in teaching so I was
doing all doing all those kind of things
first job I ever had to when I moved to
Atlanta was to work for a school for
emotionally disturbed children
that job so looking back that was sort
of a strange journey of education
teaching bartending then I went up
opening up my own place at 24 met my
wife three weeks after we opened up to
play she was walking down the street saw
her and fellows are a restaurant bar it
was a bar restaurant it was like a rule
loss it was a beautiful wood bar and
there was a fine restaurant but then we
got rid of the restaurant stuff because
we knew we were a good restaurant of
people and we put in pizza ovens and we
made great pizza was it called park
bench park bench
all right park bench so you're in though
you're in the bar restaurant business in
it and it's working right I'm 24 and I'm
making a good amount of money I had some
partners but we're doing great I'm like
last is great but I knew I didn't want
to be in the bar restaurant business if
for me it wasn't about the bar
restaurant I had bigger things I wanted
to do start a nonprofit organization
called the Phoenix organization and we
raise money for youth focused cherries
so I would meet all these people at the
bar I'm 24 25 26 at the time and getting
all these young people involved to start
volunteering and we would raise money
for different charities uh-huh never
took a dime gave everything to charity
it was became very well known very
quickly like all the charity work we're
doing the volunteer project so I meet
someone who was drunk on a Friday hey
you want a volunteer in Sunday you know
it is myself somebody exactly right but
we did that and that got me involved in
the city and then I would meet different
politicians who wanted to speak to the
Phoenix organizations at one of our
meetings so then I got involved in
politics and I ran for City Council of
Atlanta no walk drew to 7,000 houses
lost that was hard because I was a
government economics major thought I was
gonna go into politics that's what I
what I really wanted to do you still
count maybe one down yeah we need to
hopefully change things with positive
leadership
uh-huh and maybe one day well you know
so we want to tell you in the back of my
mind but you don't know if you want to
put your family through that I mean if
you want to go through that or is it
even what I'm meant to do right but if I
was meant to do it if I felt the call I
go do it but during this period of time
you're doing well
you're making money yeah you got your
yeah you've got this profile as a young
person in Atlanta I mean is there a
nagging sense that you know despite the
success that this really isn't you know
the shoe that is custom-built to fit
your foot at that point no at that point
I'm moving and shaking I'm doing the
Phoenix I'm having this bar I'm like
things are great my wife and I have two
children two small children I went to go
work for a.com because I wanted to make
my my gazillion thought I was going to
make a fortune director of business
development I actually found some of the
investors who invested in the dot-com so
I thought this was going to be my path
and it was at that point I started to
feel like there was something more when
I did that because now I'm 28 29 I'm not
working for com I have bosses I'm not
doing my own thing anymore I'm not
running a restaurant I'm not doing the
Phoenix as much to make kids so someone
else took over the Phoenix so at that
point I started to feel a little lost
and like I needed to do my own thing
we decide to move to Jacksonville so now
we moved to Jacksonville sold my
restaurants back to my partners my
shares they were stealing for me so
that's one of the things that that
happened so I basically took a chunk of
money from there not a lot should have
got a lot more and that's a lesson for
people like I should have got a lot more
could have sued could have what the
legal route I took what they gave me a
fourth of what I should have got and
just left one hundred thousand dollars
you just took that and we moved to
Jacksonville we sold our house we bought
a house I have this one hundred thousand
dollars I'm not working for the dot-com
because my boss said I can go with out
of Jacksonville I needed to just fly
wherever from there and that's when my
life started to fall apart because down
we're in Jacksonville dot-com not going
great now I'm worried about the future
two small children what am I going to do
my wife and I are fighting all the time
I'm miserable I'm negative I'm unhappy
I'm making her miserable that's what
that's what no not a lot of positivity
at all now
that's yeah that's the guy that I'm not
proud of I wasn't abusive or anything
like that I was just a miserable
negative fearful unhappy person I think
unfortunately that's the condition that
a lot of people find themselves and if
not most people you know just trying to
make a living trying to do what's right
with food on the table not totally
satisfied in their career but not really
sure there's any other options or if
anything else out there would even fill
that void and so you just live your life
and you go about your day and nothing
changes and you develop thick skin and
just sort of tolerate it and you kind of
bottle up that resentment or
dissatisfaction and occasionally it
comes out sideways and you can't get you
get it up in relationship for I mean you
know what I mean right so but why do
some make the change like you did and I
did and why do some dough that's what I
I wonder I think it's pain you know I
told your Vedas I heard I heard these
paint paint you know when the pain is is
enough then you take the action you
don't have to be in pain to make that
change but it makes it a lot easier when
you feel like your back is all the way
up against the wall but some take the
pain they escape yeah well I tried that
too right you know what I mean and I
played that out until that didn't work
anymore and just created more cooking
for all kinds of different ways of
dealing with it in unproductive ways and
even the last thing I wanted to do was
to do it the hard way but you know I
exploited every other option and until
that was the only one that was lost so
how did that work for you for me it was
pain and I remember my wife threatened
to leave me she said I love you but I'm
not going to spend my life mm-hmm with
someone who makes me so miserable you
better change
we're over I may leave right now
I'm like no no don't don't leave no I
got in my hands and knees and at the
time were you aware that your your
marriage was teetering on that level or
was that or we because a lot of guys are
just like we're checked out man we're
like I thought it was all right what do
you mean really this is a lot it's
actually you know the
the female partner who's like hey man
this ain't goin so good
I knew it was bad we were fighting a lot
and it was just it was not good so I
wasn't surprised but the reality of her
words hit me like a ton of bricks
and that was a huge moment where I was
like no I do not want her to leave I
don't want to lose her I'll do whatever
it takes I said and I'll change so that
pain that fight was one of the worst
moments in my life but also led to the
best of what I get to do now because I
remember saying what am I born to do why
am I here I know I'm here for a reason
like why am I so miserable and I asked
that question yet two observations on
that I mean the first is we're so quick
to judge things that happen to us as bad
or good and you know I look at so many
things that I so many times where I
thought this is the biggest disaster
ever and they become you know the
foundation for the greatest thing that
ever happened to you so you know I
always say embrace those moments and
understand that those are your those are
your divine opportunities if you're
paying attention if you're awake enough
to recognize them and have the sort of
mental acuity and awareness to
understand that this is an opportunity
and the second thing is is the action
that was taken right because a lot of
people could have undergone that and
sunk lower or you know said fu or you
know any number of different things so
when you said okay I'll do whatever it
takes
like what did that mean like what did
that look like what were the actions
that you took well one would you say I
just love what you said is Gallup ask
people to identify the worst event in
their life and the best and they kind of
80% correlation between the two yeah
that's somehow the worse event will lead
to the best if you're willing to change
if you're willing to move forward well I
also think culturally were kind of set
up to perceive to like avoid pain avoid
failure if something like that happens
to you you failed your you know not a
good person or whatever and that's just
wrong you know life is life stuff
happens and the more we can like reserve
that kind of judgment over these things
we feel like oh I'm not playing the game
right because I'm having relationship
issues or financial issues I think leads
people astray rather than forward you
know that I believe that and you see
that every dysfunction you can see in
society and people's personal
dysfunction can be traced back to the
fact that they want to escape and they
don't want to deal with pain they want
to avoid pain whether it's drug
addiction drinking whether it's
pornography whether it's video game
addiction whatever it may be because we
don't want to feel we're encouraged to
escape right movies go to you know it's
like everywhere you look we're bombarded
with messaging that wants us to escape
that says a good life is a life of
escape a life of luxury a life of you
know luxuriating and like avoiding
difficult situations and pain and
challenge and you know you and I we know
every guest I've ever had on this
podcast will tell you that the paths are
leading at a really fulfilling life is
one of you know welcoming those
hardships I just had I just had a guest
on the show the other day this woman
Samantha gash
unbelievable ultra runner a former
lawyer she just ran across India she's
on all these incredible things in her
life and she told me something
interesting I had never heard which is I
think she said Jason you were there the
root the root of the word passion which
comes from the interests say that
ancient Greek yeah the Latin root is to
suffer right and the inextricable length
between these two things like if you
want to live passionately then you have
to welcome the suffering that these two
things it kind of it's kinda like what
you just said that the worst thing and
the best thing are so closely aligned
its duality everything is duality so
there's no suffering without love we
suffer because we love so you have to
have one with the other you get them
both so we want to avoid pain I always
say don't avoid the pain stay in the
game embrace the pain my son is a
classic example of that like he doesn't
want to feel that
Payne so he does escape various ways
with videogames or whether it's social
media whether it's he loves comics anime
and so I'll see him reading these anime
just to escape life and I think no no
feel it are big things we talk about
feel it it's okay to feel it
human beings are meant to feel you can
see a doctor you get surgery you get an
injury and what do they do right away
they prescribe you pain pills and they
say stay ahead of the pain
what's wrong with feeling pain we're
meant to feel it it's meant we're meant
to be human don't run from it embrace it
keep moving forward yeah and I think
emotional pain you know acute emotional
pain can give you the sense that it's
going to kill you like it can be so
powerful that you actually think you're
going to die you know that you will do
anything to get out of it drugs alcohol
you know sex porn whatever but it's only
by staying in it that you realize like
there's one thing that will happen for
sure and that that feeling will change
it will morph and and you will still be
breathing when that happens and with
that comes experience that gives you the
confidence and the wherewithal to then
navigate the next difficult situation
that comes along it's just like being in
the gyms like doing push-ups but for
your emotional body yeah it's the ebb
and flow of life my wife want me to go
on take the depressants because I was
depressed and I said no I'm not doing
that like I can do this naturally now
I'd like to say everyone should do what
I did but for me I said no I could do
this naturally I don't need to take care
of the presence so I saw these walks of
gratitude I started to pray walks on the
beach did that begin when you were still
working for the faltering calm yes yeah
so you're down in Jacksonville you're
kind of having an existential crisis
render you man's life about what you're
doing you're fighting with your wife
you're committed to you know becoming a
better dude you're trying to figure out
what you're going to do professionally
how does it all kind of come to a head
so I'm walking I'm praying I'm doing all
these different things
and I said okay how can I make a living
and what am I meant to do so writing and
speaking came to me my how did that come
to you I said God why am I here
what am I meant to do and this is going
on in a context of kind of this
spiritual exploration that you're not
religious at all right I just grew up
nice Jewish kid yeah just spiritual you
know the secret of like Long Island Long
Island get the Long Island South Island
yeah yeah well you know I you know Jesse
Hitler the names had so familiar he's
one of the co-owners of the Atlanta
Hawks okay anyway he's got the same
accent as you attacked by the target
reminds me that's funny
so yeah Guam Island Jewish do it a lot
of Buddhism meditation reading a lot of
books by the Dalai Lama and this was in
part a response to your wife kind of you
know pulling your covers
I was actually was not going I was that
was going a lot of my 20s my wife was
really into that we were both into that
we connected over that we would Deepak
Chopra would come to Atlanta we'd go see
Deepak speak and we were really just
into that movement Carolyn Mase and you
know and healing and the enemy of
healing and just various things like
that she already had that was part of
your Constitution yeah I had it I was I
was seeking I was a big seeker you know
so I would consider myself very
spiritual but I never really prayed in
to God like help me which is what
happened that's what you're doing and
you got an answer yes I did I mean you
know you don't always get an answer but
I had an answer and like a lightning
bolt and that wasn't like you will be a
writer a beaker no it just came to me
too like a and it still comes to this I
get it all the time it's more but
knowing like I hear words but it's more
like it's instantaneous so it's not like
I hear it audibly but I hear it and it's
writing and speaking
really what am I to read and speak about
didn't know but that's what came to
Matmos high that's what I'm going to do
and I love Ken Blanchard who taught a
Cornell and wrote the one minute manager
I was inspired by books like Johnson
Livingston Seagull and by Richard Bach
and illusions which inspired Augmon Dean
of the greatest salesman the road less
traveled
I read that book that really impacted me
I read that when I was reading when I
was like probably 20 years old
mm-hmm so I was into these books and
into these writers and when writing and
speaking came to myself he had like it
made sense like okay that's why I'm here
that's what I meant to do but I couldn't
just say all right honey I'm going to be
a writer and speaker I don't know how
I'm afraid provide for the family you go
to work and I'm going to do that I
didn't want her to go to work I wanted
to provide so I got back in the
restaurant business and decided to open
up a Moe's Southwest Grill because I had
friends who started the original Moe's
they were only about four in the country
at the time all in Atlanta we became the
fifth Mose first one in Florida and the
second mortgage our home $20,000 in
credit cards that money that I got from
my partners that I sold the restaurant
put that in that in and that was
everything we had I mean literally we
had nothing else it was everything we
had we put into that restaurant right
it's a great story too because you were
sort of contemplating this but then it
wasn't until you went out to the movies
with your friends right that you had
another sort of lighting problem right
we were thinking if we were thinking
about doing it and we were talking about
it but nothing was working the landlord
was being difficult Moses being
difficult and we went to the movies
which we were supposed to go to a
different theatre but our friend said no
no we're going to see Planet of the Apes
potential town completely examiner was
playing the only parking space available
with the one that was right in front of
the spa where he's supposed to do the
Moe's and I said to my wife I'm getting
the feeling that we're supposed to do
the Moe's said I am too
boom okay let's do it I called up the
landlord he was awesome called up Mose
they were awesome the next day like it
was synchronicity like you and I had
yeah the manor she was just flown in the
right direction yeah I mean it was just
a girl with that you just go with it and
some things you just you know you just
can't explain I mean even just like
you're you coming over here like a day
before you come over here my daughter is
watching you know what the hell and
after watching that she says mom and dad
I decide I'm gonna go vegan just after
watching that she has no idea that you
and I are talking that you're coming
over here to do this
that we do this podcast together and she
watches that movie and inspired us so
much that she's like I'm gonna be a
vegan I mean what are the odds
that's crazy she just walked in the
kitchen oh my gosh she's been really
quiet that that's guy even here that's
great words behind you yeah I love that
kind of stuff right like why is it like
of all the taught like why is that
happening the day before you know and
you could pass it off whatever
coincidence but I like to you know I
like to embrace the beautiful mystery of
life and I choose to believe that
there's more at play with things like
that oh yeah it's definitely mystery
yeah
so you open up this restaurant and
that's that's given you a little bit of
a cushion to now explore the writing
wells maybe not right away now because
the goal is to open up the restaurant
keep the job calm uh-huh and get the
restaurant go and make it successful and
then quit right but I lost my job three
weeks before the restaurant open and so
now I have no money coming in no
insurance for your money from the
restaurant all of it to the restaurant
we have one month to save things in our
bank account how are we going to provide
for our family when it takes a while for
restaurants to make a profit and what
happens if it doesn't so I violated all
business plans but it was where my faith
was born because my wife and I went out
there we hired the movie theater right
next to us all the cars we went to all
the business myriad promoting catering
just started marketing the heck out of
the place to get business broke even
right away though wasn't losing money
but wasn't making money right it's easy
to have faith when everything's going
your way right you know I mean like
faith is meant to be tested like do you
really have faith all right I'm going to
pull that calm job away from you I'm
going to make sure you only got a month
to sit on and then we'll see if you're
really serious about this right because
I think that's again that's another
thing that were kind of encouraged to
run away from but that is almost you
know universally like beautifully
orchestrated for you to really go in
like do you mean that you really want to
do this all right well I'm going to make
you work for it we'll see if you really
want this you know what I mean yeah yeah
and I love that because so many people
reach out to me now and they are full of
fear
about taking the next step but I could
speak for my own experience I did it I
lived it I stepped out on the faith I
went through my fear so I can help that
person who was thinking about the next
step where they're worried about that or
I can tell they don't have to say
they're full of fear and I'll let them
know
you're full of fear and if you really
truly want to create your future you
have to embrace that move through it
take a step of faith a leap of faith
sometimes to create the life that you
want and if you're not willing to do
that if you're not able to do that then
I don't believe the universe God
whatever you want to call it will get
behind you to create what you need to
create I believe God will move heaven
and earth when you're on the path and
you're willing to take that leap of
faith to go do what you're meant to do
yeah I believe I believe that to be true
I mean I have my version that story you
know and it involves pending foreclosure
and cars getting repossessed and they're
like not being able to like you know pay
for our garbage to get I mean quick you
know like really meeting my maker you
know on a fundamental level to like test
me to say like alright are you really
committed to like can you burn in this
flame and come out the other side and I
think love that you know with that you
know you said like alright well you know
maybe you know God will move heaven and
earth to get behind you if you have that
faith and I think you know one
distinction I would make or maybe we can
kind of clarify here is that just
because you have faith doesn't mean
you're you're immune from fear you know
and I mean like I was I had faith but I
was scared too you know it's what he
said I was trying to take action and
despite that fear yeah I wouldn't say
that I wasn't afraid my wife was less
afraid actually she was like no this is
what we're doing we're in all the way
like you just left out faith you've got
to like not think you got to like expand
your mind outside the paradigm of social
expectations and this rule book that
you've lived your life by and think more
broadly like she had a lot more of that
kind of strength than I did and I would
be like okay look you've got to go but
like playing afraid but still moving
forward you know you would the very
person when they give you strength first
of all I think that's important here
because like my wife same thing like she
didn't yell at me she wasn't mad like
how could you lose your job she said
it's okay it's gonna be all right like
some how would it get through this and I
remember a friend of owed me money
called up out of the blue and pay me
back the money he owed that helped carry
us for a month I mean it was like these
little things that happened I sold a
franchisee on Mo's potential franchisee
so I got a kickback fee for selling
their franchise that character right
comes right at the right moment right
when you think you can't go any further
it's like the analogy that I always use
that there's a there's a really old
Popeye cartoon and in the cartoon
sweetpea
remember the little baby yeah sweetie
like escaped and is crawling around and
finds herself on a construction site and
she crawls up onto a like a girder beam
that gets pulled up by crane and swings
around and like right when she's about
to crawl off the end it like lines up
with another girder and she calls it and
it's like it that repeats repeats and
repeats until she's finally back on the
ground like right wait at that moment
where you think it's going to be a
disaster that that thing shows up and
it's just it's just it might not be what
you want but it's just enough of what
you need to keep you going both and I
got is the universe showing up like I
said in final trial like the you know
when your faith is true when your aim is
true the universe will conspire to
support you and and that doesn't mean
it's going to be comfortable or easy or
show up in the package that you would
prefer but somehow it's going to work
yeah and I got the call from a friend
who said we want to learn about wireless
technology the Dobby had worked for can
you teach us I said well I don't know
about the technology because I'm not a
technology guy so I'm probably not the
right fit he said no teach us how to
sell it
hmm I said okay I can do that you say
you want to speak and then here's a
speaking opportunity they pay me
thirteen thousand dollars for six weeks
of consulting I'll never forget I mean
it was a miracle and as that as that
money came in it carried us until the
last dime and out of our account and
then we made our first profit at a
restaurant like it was clockwork and
that money ran out from the consulting
we made our first profit in the
restaurant six months later yeah we were
just literally hanging by a thread and
just finding any way to pay the bills
and eating it Moe's you
oops right everyday about trusting but
trusting but like you said full of fear
but yet also having faith scared but
taking action and just trusting that
somehow someway it would work out now I
did say this God please provide for my
family and I'll do your work and for me
that meant give back make the world
better you know do do the work of giving
to others and I never will forget that
and I always am tested on that like is
it about you John or is it about you
giving back down this is about the fact
that you know you're writing these books
but what are you doing to help others
and I'm always push and challenge and is
that usually coming from fear or is it
or is it coming from you know a more
forward thinking perspective so would
think so we think yo know that what I'm
what I'm saying is like when your boo
but like it was a combination but it's
like am I doing this just out of my yeah
because I don't want to be a failure or
or do I really want to sir you know what
I mean like I think it's combination of
games it's like you can't say right it
was like it was like I will like provide
for me and my family and I will do your
work which really which I never said
that before so I don't even know where
it came from but it came to me in that
moment of yes fear please provide but
I'll make sure that my life is not about
me going forward like I had to die to
myself because I was met in many ways
self-consumed
and it was always about success success
success it was about feeling successful
in my father left when I was born and I
think you know that abandonment issue
people who have abandoned issues always
want to prove those people wrong so I
think that's probably never meant to
that so for me it was always about being
successful to prove other people wrong
ultimately that was a defining moment
where it became no longer about me being
a success but about making a difference
and so even when I wrote the energy bus
and was rejected by those publishers and
even when I went on a tour what if I
like came out and had five people in
every city and ten people in other
cities
not a big crowds yes I wanted to be a
person of value I was going out there
wanted to be someone of value doing this
but what drove me ultimately was to go
make a difference because just your own
success will not carry you that far I
don't think no I think that there's a
there's a beautiful mystical spiritual
equation that occurs when you go from
how am I going to get mine or you know
how can I win in this situation or what
am I going to get out of this too how
can I contribute how can I serve how can
I help you get yours and if you can
shift your mindset into that and your
actions follow for some reason your life
gets better and it gets a bit better by
a multiple of five to ten to twenty and
then and then on and it's not like I'm
not hardwired to be that way but when I
can get into that space like I have to
practice gratitude to be great I'm not
unnaturally grateful person I'm an
irritable you know a mental fear-based
you know like I have to do a lot of work
to like just scratch the surface of
those but when I do my lit way better
notice we all have this physical nature
and we have a spiritual nature and I
think it's the battle between those two
of the flesh and physical nature of
survival of dominance of getting what I
want but then we have the spiritual
nature which is about love and
compassion and forgiveness and giving
and servant serving others and caring so
I think we have this two natures that
are at war with each other but I think
we we sort of approach those from our
perspective of how can I get more of
that in my life how can I get more love
how can I get more appreciation okay
whatever as opposed to like how come if
when the truth is in order to the way to
get those is to is to be giving those
right to be giving those a way to be
practicing that yeah the more you want
it don't seek it give it and then when
you give it it comes back to you tenfold
right it's the generosity principle
right right right yeah all right so you
get this consulting gig and then you sit
down you get channeled you know the idea
for this first book
you sit down you write this thing in
three and a half weeks right and then
you're getting rejected by all these
publishers yeah that that book happened
after actually I sold the restaurants oh
so it was I was out speaking in Oregon
and I wasn't doing a lot of speaking but
but it was going okay two or three a
month maybe and I loved it but the
restaurants were weighing me down and I
was reading a magazine that said how to
value a business when selling on the way
home a different magazine that said
you're thinking about selling at the
time yeah but then there's an article in
a business magazine then a completely
different business magazine one was Inc
one was entrepreneur success like was
different magazines and the other one
said how to how to value your business
when selling to different magazine to
different articles the sign universe was
speaking to you again yes walk in the
house said to my wife we're going to
sell the restaurant it's time this is
around 2005 and new his time so sell the
restaurants to another franchisee in
town who who bought my stores and had
enough money to carry us maybe for a
couple years
year or two maybe two years and said all
right I'm now going to put a hundred
percent into writing and speaking but
six months go by and nothing's happened
have you been writing or reblocked her
now I had written another book that I
don't really talk about much but I wrote
another book called energy addict 101
ways to energize your life so it was
about physical energy mental energy
emotional energy spiritual energy got on
the Today Show hmm so I thought my life
was going to take off after got a Today
Show like alright that's it you've
arrived I've arrived after The Today
Show
like kind of little buzz I've done
everything just drying up it was it was
wild it was like my greatest dream and
then everything dries up at and that was
2006 or something that was around 2005
Wow
so 2006 we sell the restaurants now it
transitions to 2006 six months after
some of the restaurants nothing's
happening everything's drying out not a
lot of speaking I'm like okay now I have
met a year and a half of income left
whatever this doesn't work what am I
going to do so I'm walking again a
little fearful and I'm praying and the
idea for the energy bus came to me
and that's when I wrote that in about
three and a half weeks after that moment
right I'm like literally just three and
a half wait three and a half weeks I'll
never I wrote this book now I did have
an agent from the previous book Ariel
Ford who works with the POC and she
writes her own books as well her sister
was Debbie Ford and REO pitches around
and I got rejected by always publish
with you and you're left with more fear
another well it's another test of faith
yes are you really supposed to be a
writer right like what am I going to do
is just doesn't work out and I thought I
wrote something that might make a
difference
my wife said it's pretty good do you
know she just like loved it she thought
it was okay didn't know was going to
sell a million copies as it has now you
know that no one had a clue no one
thought it would do anything I didn't
know I thought I had some that was cool
it would make a difference and I was you
know positive energy was all about
positive energy and it just to me it
made sense but I remember not even
having the ten rules when I sat down and
started writing it had a few and then
one ruler to the other which led to the
other which went to the other and I'm
like oh I got my ten rules now and so we
just kept putting it out there
kept getting rejected kept getting
rejected and then one day I'm in John
while I'm in that I'm sorry Barnes an
oval looking at the bookstore and
looking at the Shelf and seen all these
books on the shelf and I notice John
Wiley and Sons was a publisher of a
bunch of business bucks and I considered
this more of a business done and I asked
my agent if we send it to Wiley she said
no we had it I said senator Wiley said
okay she sends it to wiling she sends it
to the health editor because she was
willing to help she was more in the
health side of things the health editor
shoulda thrown the way but didn't gave
it to the business editor said here Matt
take a look at this he takes a look at
it this man handed to his assistant
Shannon Bardo she reads it the main
characters named George she has a best
friend with a husband named George and
she decides she wants to do the book
right cuz she actually remembered me
from the Today Show see oh she knew that
yeah but yeah and then she
she was new right she'll get a job for a
few months and she went to bat for you
with her boss leather boss he said if
this doesn't go well could be your
career and she said now I want to do it
I believe in it yeah and they go we
don't have about we don't have a lot of
money can't give you a big advance I
said I don't care I just want the book
out there and so the book comes out and
right away it becomes a huge hit in
Korea right let me share before yeah
and so that was surprised have you have
you been able to figure out what now
that happened like with me some new
speed and they go right like no-one
knows like there's got to be patient
zero for that like somehow somebody got
it to somebody who got it to somebody
they were they were in Singapore at a
book show where they were doing the
foreign rights where they're showing the
farm publishers different books and
there were two publishers that started a
bidding war over the book and that's
what happened I see and so I think they
probably put some heft behind pushing it
out there yeah once it won out the
foreign rights sold for like one hundred
and twenty thousand dollars that's crazy
people don't realize in publishing how
de minimis foreign rights are I know
almost no a thousand dollars here this
is a go get like an email from a great
deal fifteen hundred dollars for France
I'm like what and my mom had had she
read the manuscript but she passed away
before the book came out so like did my
mom speak Korean you know you know I
reserved my mom was you know she was
some past life shooting with exclusive
Jewish mom she had a strong personality
so I think I always felt like my mom was
up there and heavy like just advocating
about the have like come on just help my
son help my son
so you're huge in Korea but nobody in
the United States knows anything about
you or this book despite the fact that
you've been on The Today Show
well I think it's interesting because
you know there was a day at a time where
if you were on the Today Show that was
it like you were you arrived and doors
started swingin wide open you know the
days of being a stand-up comedian and
going on Carson and then overnight
you're a household name we don't live in
that world anymore there and you know
I've heard it many times from authors
who go on the Today Show or the other
version of that and they think it's
going to be their defining moment and
it's like nothing you know because the
way we consume
content has changed so drastically
that's a passive audience right as
opposed to for example a podcast where
people are already they already want to
hear what you have to say they're a
captive audience
and they're on their device so it's a
click away from buying a book or what
have you but having had that experience
I think actually like you might have
thought this is terrible but actually
that was the fuel that you know provided
the motivation for you to go on this
crazy tour you know I don't know how
many cities you went 28 it's one person
at a time connecting as deeply as
possible as opposed to you know doing it
on a surface level in a broad way which
is kind of like what the Today Show is
but the sedation even then this was 2005
2006 even back then it was still the
place to me and I was out of four times
that a four week series so I should have
got my also they but here's them if it
doesn't if it becomes something big I
never write the energy bus and so I
really believe it didn't take off
because what I was meant to write the
energy bus but I was also meant to
change uh-huh because you weren't ready
I wasn't ready and my spiritual maturity
and growth hadn't happened yet and so I
was still at a place where yes I wrote
these books yes I had changed a lot of
positive ways but I still had to
surrender a lot more I still had to come
to my knees a lot more and and truly
just surrendered to a greater power and
that hadn't happened yet but it only
happened when I wrote that allowed me to
write the energy boss and that happened
the energy bus happened after I came to
my knees right and if it would have
happened from the Today Show which it
should have four week series it didn't
looking back again what I thought was
going to change my life actually did in
a better way yeah that's a great
perspective to havona yeah so you go on
this crazy tour one person at a time if
I've been shown up at a bookstore the
crazy cat lady yeah oh yeah you guys up
yes yeah so yeah like those like the one
person that wants to talk to you for an
hour and you know about publishing they
never want to talk about your book they
want to talk about their book they
always want to talk about their own buck
you know and I actually made a free
webinar that I give to people all the
time now when they want to talk about
how to publish a book I said hey I did
webinar for you and for people who want
to know so that you don't have to talk
to help people you have it right there
for them they still want to help them
right and I've maybe I could put a link
up to that
yeah Shanna I love helpful are
interested in love helping gentleman out
find their path but yeah they had we had
the most people were 100 people in Des
Moines Iowa this is like 2007 yeah 2007
right they thought Jeff Gordon was
coming that's why they share that yeah
they really did I got called Jeff like
four times so what's the what's tipping
point I mean was it just a gradual build
of awareness or were there a couple
things that kind of occurred where you
you know suddenly found herself like
suddenly like oh man now I'm selling a
lot of books and oh now I'm getting
invited to go you know speak to the
49ers or you know it was whatever team
the jaguars were the first team I spoke
to lived in Jacksonville button a friend
who was a trainer gave the book to Mike
Smith who was a defensive coordinator of
the Jaguars he gave it to Jack Del Rio
who is the head coach Jack the Rio
called me up out of the blue would love
to come be with you man with Jack and
that led to my first team ever spoke to
him again looking back how does that
happen I'm an unknown nobody I've never
worked with you know you're showing up
given anything worked with a college
team you know or even a high school team
but Jackie that was have been
intimidating very a 13-time to go into
that like all right like what am I going
to say these guys I remember walking
down the aisle towards the front of the
room the team's all sitting there Mike
theis
offensive line coach big guy coach from
Long Island and I walked by he goes from
from Long Island uh-huh and he goes
strong island as I bought rakia just
remember that moment and I walk to the
front of the room and I see Fred Taylor
Maurice jones-drew players who I watched
on TV who I loved and now I'm here to
speak to them it was really intimating
yeah but I said but has to be a moment
where you're like wow like all that
faith that I had or everything that I
went through I'm seeing the physical
manifestation I wish I was thinking that
way now in that moment and rush respect
looking oh yeah retrospect yeah but in
the moment no you're doing the moment
out of those in the
when I said you know what I said you
have something that can inspire them
that can make a difference go for it no
fear go for it you only live once and so
that was my mindset because and being an
athlete I had a loud fear to ruin those
moments I had been in those moments
where the moment was bigger than me and
I didn't do well so I always have this
desire in those big moments to not allow
fear to keep me from that moment but to
embrace it and just move over the block
right that's that's one thing that that
a Gervais talks about all the time like
there are no big moments there's just a
moment right right foundering inside
that that's all right man if I had a
doubt it out it's okay
it's life man like hanging on him you
want to answer it no yeah Jason Ken so
you know in the wake of the first book
success you've gone on to write you've
written seventeen books that means
you're like writing two books a year
right it's crazy yeah a prolific output
and and you know one of the things that
I'm dealing with right now you know
finding also came out in 2012 and five
years and I'm starting to unpack the
next book and it's taken me a really
long time
and I've been really blocked and finding
all so I just flowed right I mean
obviously I know the story it was in
certain respects even though it was
first time out there it was kind of an
easy book to write because like I knew
the story obviously and this is the one
I'm working on now the little bit
trickier but it's more than that and I
think it's something that you've
experienced which is you have a success
and then you feel this internal pressure
that the next one's got to be better or
if it's not as good then you're going to
be you know what I mean like that and I
know you've gone through that so we
talked about that a little short
yeah we don't to let people down we
don't want people to think maybe we're a
fraud I think it goes back to the
imposter syndrome I Who am I to be
writing these books having other books
become successful I'll read what I wrote
years ago with energy bus or training
camp plan I'm thinking I didn't remember
writing that like how did I write that
and so there's a scary feeling of
writing something new and it not being
good I think the more success you have
the more few you have because the father
you have to fall now and a lot of people
think Oh
once you have success there's no fear I
think the fear is greater so as an
artist like you are it's about the work
I believe it's about not thinking about
what the outcome is going to be right
other than I have a vision for it I know
that's create a masterpiece so I'm going
to my love my heart my soul into
creating what I'm meant to create to
make it the best it can be
and that should just be the only focused
so the the craftsman is not thinking
about failing the crafts are the only
thinking about the craft and doing the
work and working to create a masterpiece
so it's outside in versus inside out so
we're looking outside at the expectation
at the height and fear is outside of
what people will think but to write the
masterpiece it's basically writing what
you feel meant to write and writing from
within that which energizes you that way
you're passionate about that what you
want to share and just go to that place
of sharing it yeah I like that I mean I
think you know when you wrote the energy
bus like you got to make it hat like
there's nothing else going on right like
you do so here they are right because
and you don't have any you know beyond
your family they're in the sort of
financial pressure that you were feeling
I'm sure there weren't a lot of people
pulling on you for your time
right but now your phone's ringing all
the time and all those opportunities are
awesome and you get to go and like go
and go to these cool stadiums these
amazing athletes that you know you
respect and revere it's all good right
but at some point I would imagine you
have to learn how to say no because now
is my writing time or you know and those
it becomes a different decision tree you
have to say you know what I'm going to
do the art of writing and make that part
of my craft and make time for that
instead of saying oh I'm gonna take this
speaking gift like you have to give up
some speaking gigs and that means money
to write what you're meant to write so
what I try to do is write every December
when things slow down
I don't its we did I wrote two books a
year because it didn't feel like it
so you thousand seven to ten years right
so it works that way actually swearing
fifteen books because the other two were
were probably years before that I see
that so fifteen books right only fifteen
ten years right okay and the shark
goldfish in positive dog arose a real
small yeah I know story and one word I
wrote with Dan and Jimmy and so we wrote
that together right so I would say you
know maybe it's about 11 or 12 that I
wrote alone during that time so almost
one or a little more than one a year
every December all the fables are
definitely every December and that's
that spiritual time of sitting down and
writing and making time for the work but
before every book there's that fear that
it's not going to be good or that it's
not going to come this time I think I
feel that before we talk what happens if
I don't have it today it's like would
happen with the way what's your analysis
of getting right do you have like a
prepared like keynote type thing or you
just get up there and try to channel so
I have a the energy of the audience
right I have a framework of what I'm
going to share so if the audience is a
business audience it's a different kind
of talk I spoke to Medtronic in
Minneapolis the leaders of Medtronic dis
Riesling and that was based on the tower
positive leadership and I knew what
their struggles were because I talk to
them like three or four times and really
went through their issues their
challenges the people in the audience
what they're going through
so I crafted a custom talk based on my
principles but to share the message that
they needed to hear
but that homework was was really
necessary to deliver what they wanted
and they loved it which is grab like I
was so proud of that because we had done
so much preparation for it and it really
hit them home hit home so then other
talks you know work with Delanie and see
the merger of those two companies have
to find out what they're going through
the merger leaders coming together and
then when I'm working with a sports team
again what challenges are they facing I
go to a school district okay tell me
about what with the themes are for the
year what are your issues whether your
challenges so every talk is customized
which I like and I have to prepare for
it but it's basically I have all these
principles and like all right I'm going
to speak about this that that and then I
have to just put them together
what story goes here what application
goes here how do I want to end this one
what's my beginning so based on all
these talks you give over the years you
sort of put together a framework of what
the talks going to be announcer so in
the Venn diagram you know sports and
business definitely overlap right and a
lot of that sort of leadership and
teamwork principles I would imagine are
you know equally applicable or similar
but how do you you know how do you
differentiate like when you're talking
to a sports team versus you know meeting
with a division of a company is it the
same or is it you know is it a different
language are the principles that they
vary at all or give I think principles
are the same you know I have a power of
a positive educator talk they give to
educators and I speak to a lot of school
districts in August's so they're
beginning their school year I talked to
the principals the leaders and a lot of
times maybe 6,000 teachers of a district
all together in a big kind of arena I
love that I love making a difference in
education like I charge less for it
because I want to do it a lot of
business speakers will say no I'm not
going to do it they don't pay that I
want to go do it because education I
believe is where we're going to change
the future of our country we're going to
have an impact so for me is more
personal and passionate and I know that
I got the master's in teaching at Emory
for a reason because I never taught but
that's what you do you are a teacher
fundamentally I mean speaking the book
yeah nearly jint your teaching I would
consider myself a teacher more than a
speaker I hate the term motivational
speech it's a terrible I do not see
myself as a do they call you that when
you open on no but you do give a talk I
know they take ultra-marathoner
you know legend this I don't like it
well
maybe somebody does I mean I don't think
of myself like that but you know it
sounds so corny it sounds like you're
you're coming in with some canned thing
I know that it's a schlocky I hate that
and so I hate the term motivational
speaker so I would say I'm a teacher
who's teaching principles for leadership
with principles for teamwork or
principles for positivity and how to
overcome these challenges or I will
speak at entrepreneurs about growing
your business and building your brand
and overcoming fear and the challenges
that entrepreneurs face my book the
carpenter I wrote because I wanted that
to be about entrepreneurs who are going
to work on their craft and they've gone
from the carpenter to the cross right
and and and show up every day and do the
work ignore the critic show up and work
on your craft no type of naysayers I'm
too busy creating my work mmm-hmm what
is the thing that you see the most in
terms of the Achilles heel of whether
it's the sports team or the division of
the fortune 500 company like where are
people tripping themselves up
necessarily but you know commonly great
question I believe the biggest
challenges leaders are facing today
companies teams organizations are facing
today are one leaders without focusing
on their culture they don't take the
time to focus on their culture and say
like who are we what are we about what
do we want to build what kind of
culturally we want to create what kind
of impact we want to have the great
organizations do and those are the ones
that everyone talks about but enough or
too many are not talking about it and
more need to they're too busy putting
out fires they're too busy just trying
to create reverse oh yeah I talked about
the fact that they're focusing on the
fruit of the tree and ignoring the root
the culture is your root and if you
ignore the root and focus on the fruit
the tree dies but if you invest in the
root and make it your number one
priority you always never great supply
of fruit so it's countercultural a lot
of time it's harder because you have to
invest more in that root but over time
you get great fruit so that's sort of
the dynamic and the kind of analogy I
share with leaders to help them
understand that and they get it so
that's my goal get leaders to focus on
their culture
a lot don't second mistake they make is
they ignore the negativity that exists
in teams and organizations so they don't
want to confront it no one likes to deal
with negativity and actual confront the
challenges that exist so the reason why
the energy bus has been so popular is
because it deals with energy vampires
and it deals with negativity on a team
and trying to convert it or transform it
to positivity right and so they make the
mistake of ignoring the negativity so
I'm big believer in height confront
confront it with the intent of
transforming it if you can't transform
it then you have to remove it too many
leaders today though they'll say you
know the energy bus is like rum either
all my bus or off the bus and I get the
emails all the time like my boss is the
biggest energy vampire Baldr given us
your book taking another feed yeah so
what do you do when the leader of the
pack is the vampire yeah like biggest
challenge you know what I mean because
that's the person who's charged with
crafting and creating that culture I
mean I think you know I don't I have
less experience in the corporate I mean
I was a lawyer for a while but less
experience without more experience in
sports but I think there's a sense that
the culture is what it is like oh the
tees are the guys on the team that's the
dynamic and there's nothing we can do
about it as opposed to this idea that it
can be it can be shaped right with some
with some intentional you know effort
and exercise yeah once you know what you
stand for every decision you make is
easy and so every culture every leader
needs to say what do we stand for as a
culture what are we about and you just
failed it in the fact that so many
leaders think it's static but actually
culture is dynamic every day you're
creating culture by what you think by
what you do what you do and by what you
say the habits you create so culture
drives the behaviors the expectations
those drive the habits and that
ultimately creates the future so it all
starts with the culture we create and
the one thing that leaders do is they
create great cultures great leaders
create great cultures and we see it over
and over again and the bad leaders don't
I very rarely go into organizations that
have bad cultures why they're not going
to bring someone like me in right
because they're not looking at it
they're not looking at they don't care
about it so I love that you said
cultures dynamics because it really is
and and every day you are either
creating it or you allowing it to create
you dad was swimming with Clemson you
know national championship just this
year he has a book like 18 inches thick
that's all about their culture and every
year he goes over that book page by page
with his coaching staff for four full
days Wow in a retreat page by page
all right this year we did this we
talked about this here's we did this it
seems but not as like why would you do
that
and he said because we can't forget what
made this program what it is we're going
to go back to our basics it'd be nice if
you summarized it in one page but no
page by page yeah yeah yeah of this book
and that you know a positive functional
culture is is improved is it like how do
you like how am I trying to phrase this
you know a positive culture whether it's
not a sports team or in a corporation is
going to be infused with connectivity
which is something you talk about all
the time right like how do you foster
that connectivity and it comes down to
caring right like whether you're an
employee or you're a member of the team
you have to care feel connected to these
people you're going to care more that's
going to trickle down and sort of foster
that kind of culture that you're trying
to phone that right yeah positive
leaders they unite the organization but
connect with the individual so they
create unity but then they vote develop
relationships with the people they lead
and that's the other thing leaders don't
make time to invest in relationships
they want results but Andy Stanley's had
rules with that relationship lead to
rebellion I can't get this guy to do
they do what I want them to do well like
you don't even know what he's going
through right cuz you haven't taken the
time to like invest yourself in his life
like if he feels like you care then he's
going to deliver for you I mean he was
fundamental it's soon but I've seen it
you know in the law firms that I've
worked in like people are so busy that
you know the partner will tell me or
would tell somebody why
I got time for that you know I mean it
takes a diligent you know focus to like
say I'm going to make that time and that
will pay off later because I'll have
people that you know feel like they're
part of this team and I'm trying to
create and they're going to they're
going to work that extra you know hour
or two and that's why you see like Wall
Street companies like Wall Street
businesses they don't have the time for
that no one's focused and cultures like
no we're making money this is what we're
doing we're law fair we don't have time
for that sports teams know we're doing
our XO knows what a time for culture now
we need to focus on those other ones
we're going to have a lot of turnover a
lot of turnover a lot of fires a lot of
issues and then you see the Warriors and
then you see the Spurs and then you see
the Patriots
and then you see Southwest Airlines and
then you see great companies that have
great cultures and you see sustained
success you see sustained leadership and
great leadership and then you see the
fruit ongoing of those organizations and
so it's like why don't people get this I
get so clear I guess if it if they got
it everyone got I wouldn't have books to
write or talks to give because people
would just get it right I mean well Pat
Riley makes pretty clear you know he's
pretty transparent in his coaching
methods and his results speak for
themselves so why isn't every coach
trying to emulate that right like that's
the big question like why would everyone
do what they're doing that one huh they
want to replicate the success but
they're not willing I think to replicate
all that goes into creating a great
culture all the time all the energy all
the effort it takes a lot of work I mean
you have to invest a lot to create a
great culture to be a parent at two
teenagers 19 and 17 takes so much to
invest in my kids it'd be a lot easier
just to say you know what I'm going to
do my thing today I'm surfing all day
I'm playing tennis I'm going to do this
you guys deal with it but I know years
later I'm going to regret that you know
I want them to be the best they can be
so I will invest and make time for them
knowing in the long run everyone's going
to benefit and so I think the same thing
goes for leadership like you can ignore
your people but if you ignore your
people they'll never perform at their
highest level and you'll never be the
best team that
you can be so the best leaders I have
found they provide love and
accountability a lot of love put a lot
of accountability to be the best you can
be but love comes first if I was I call
it love tough vs. tough love so for
every CEO or coach or teacher or team
captain that's listening to this there's
10 or 100 employees or team members that
are listening to the day and if you know
that I'm just trying to envision you
know sitting in their shoes and you know
my boss or my coach or my teacher
doesn't get it and I don't know what to
do so we're creating a 360 assessment
that we want positive leaders or maybe
they're not positive leaders but leaders
to give to their team and say how am i
doing am i a positive leader am i
helping you be your best like actually
provide assessment that your team
answers and if you're open you'll get
some great results that can help you get
better
I had a leader tell me that you read my
book the seven seas to build a winning
team the win in a locker room first I
wrote with Mike Smith and a big chapter
is on communication and he asked his
team how am i communicating some said oh
you're great you're great you're great
now they'd said because that's what I
wanted to hear right but one said you're
not doing this you're not doing that
you're not doing that you make me feel
this way actually a couple said that he
said it changed his leadership style
became a better communicator and he's
seeing amazing results we have this one
program we call driver positive change
it's our program we help managers become
better leaders and we have a love letter
to an energy vampire exercise as part of
our training you have to write a love
letter to one of your energy vampires
and the love letter is a letter of
encouragement of belief and support like
here's what I see in you here's the grid
I see here's the great things you're
doing and you may not want to write that
letter but we have them do it well one
of the VAR managers who went through it
she reported back to us and said she did
the letter they wound up sitting down
for two hours an amazing conversation
talk more than they ever had even in
years of working there the relationship
bonded she found out she was going to a
lot of difficult
colleges wife haters uh the leader found
out that the employee was going through
a lot of challenges a lot of had a lot
of issues that's why they were so
negative and now they're like incredible
relationship it completely transformed
the leadership style she said that's
interesting you know the first part of
your answer was involved a you know
leader that is open to these ideas right
but I'm just imagining like the employee
sitting in a cubicle or in their office
where they're on a dysfunctional team
right and they're not they're not able
to you know get the get on the radar of
their boss or the person's is not
receptive right like so is the solution
I mean I guess you could shoulder some
responsibility to be a leader in that
department yourself and try to transform
it on your own or you got to leave right
you have two choices you change your
attitude and say you know what I'm going
to lead from where I am I'm not going to
complain I'm going to lead from where I
am and be a leader in an influencer in
my sphere I call it making your bus
great you may not be driving the big
boss but you can drive your bus and make
your bus great and a model for other
buses or this culture is so
dysfunctional this culture is so bad I
don't see it changing I'm going to go be
a part of a great culture and I'm going
to look for a great place to work which
is why great cultures have the pick of
people who want to work there so maybe
you want to work there but I'm on a
mission with this this new book I wrote
the power of positive leadership like I
want readers to read this book because I
wrote it because you know what you
you're number one job as a leader is to
provide an environment where you people
could do their best work and if you're
not creating that environment if you're
not being that type of leader then
you're hurting them and yourself so my
hope is that I can hopefully change as
many leaders I can or inspire them and
help them improve to be their best and
I've heard from a lot you know a lot
that have changed that have improved
that's what keeps me felt like those
emails keep me going now I have a lot
more to reach so this Ken Blanchard so
to sort of others that are out there
Patrick Lencioni or at five dysfunctions
of a team hopefully over time you know
this has an
that's the hold so that's all we can do
right but I think about that person to
keep it go and if the email I get most
from people my box is an energy vampire
what do I do
and it's always start with you on the
inside well women said while women till
we convinced by our presence be the best
that you can be and then start creating
from within and then you'll you'll
transform and you may leave but if you
leave great if you stay you'll have an
impact in the people around you right
well the one thing you can control your
own behavior and your own attitude right
and so I think when you get an email
like that you also have to parse like
what part of this is this person being a
victim right you know as opposed to
telling speaking truth to power you know
and and perhaps and there's probably a
sliding scale of that like there's a
certain kind of person that no matter
what you tell them they're always going
to say it's somebody hopefully not I
mean so right you got to like deal with
that personality type first I always
look for that when I look at is this
person to victim because I'll say
something that I think is profound and
helpful and get back and then they'll
tell you another reason why I can't do
that
yes exactly they I go okay I got it
right right right right
well another part of of what you talk
about a lot is this idea of you got to
be you got to have a telescope and you
got to have a microscope right and
there's different versions of this I
mean Gary Vee calls it you know clouds
and dirt or you know or you know that
lately
he would come up with a cooler term that
summer terms and I would know cuz of the
political is the same right like you've
got like it it's it's sort of in this
internet culture and also in the kind of
self-help world and everything it gets
packed into that it's like all about
following your passion and have a huge
dream and nobody can get in your way and
you know the universe is mine and
there's a sort of millennial entitlement
the axes that gets built into that as
well but that's great you dream big you
know what I mean but what are you doing
right now what is your next action like
what is what are the details of how
you're living your day on a
moment-by-moment hour-by-hour basis I
love that well that's the big picture
vision of the telescope of where you do
have a vision of what you want to create
we do need a vision we need a North Star
that guy does it's not some pie this guy
but no anchors it anchors what those
decisions are going to be in those micro
moments right so you have this big
picture vision that guides you like when
you have a vision that drives you with
everything that you do I have a vision
that drives made to inspire and power as
many as many people as possible
one person a time it's going back to the
tour always making a difference one
person I'm too busy for that one person
then I'm not doing the right work and
that means that someone reaches out to
me on Facebook I got a respond someone
reaches out on Twitter having a problem
I got a respond not to put not to
promote their book or to teach them how
to write a book but you have a genuine
problem with your life I'll help you
like I will make time for that so that's
my vision that guides me but then what's
the zoom focus actions you need to take
each day to realize the big picture in
the telescope so I have to do this each
day and I usually believe that we can do
three things like I believe you can
really zoom focus on three things each
day so what am i doing today to realize
that picture what's my commitment
because a lot of people have big visions
but they don't commitments to reach the
vision so I believe you have to be
committed to the vision and commitments
or greater than goals I'm a big I'm a
big fan of goals but but I'm a much
bigger fan of commitments so to explain
to me the difference so it was with an
NFL team but I asked them to write down
their goals and then I had them rip them
up after they wrote them down they took
about five minutes to write it down
you're pretty upset and then I said you
know why I'm having you rip them up now
why why they're actually angry I said
well tell me about your goals I wanna
have so many receptions so many passes
so many touchdown so many yards you know
everyone had their goals when it's
Superbowl I said don't you think every
other player in the NFL has the same
goals written down doesn't every team
right now have Superbowl as one of their
goals so only one can win a Super Bowl
so will your goals take you to where you
want to go no but your commitments well
now tell me what you're committed
in order to reach the goal one guy said
I need to spend more time in recovery I
don't recover enough I don't invest in
my recovery so my body wears down during
the season another guy said I eat too
much fast food during the season I did
it last year this year I need to eat
healthier another guy said you know my
body starts breaking down under keep
during the course of the season I got to
visit the trainer when I'm injured and
not ignore the trainer and take time
from my house they're all physical
things mostly for their body for their
recovery for their health you know and
so they were now telling me their
commitment and it was powerful where
they started saying what they're going
to be committed to one place that I must
spend more time in the film room
watching tape watching film but commit
to that it'd be interesting if you kind
of rephrase that as that being the goal
like my goal is to you know stay an
extra half an hour after practice three
days a week and do the extra fundamental
drills or well you know whatever it is
like some guy said that yeah some guys
actually said I'm going to do this
system this for extra time I'm gonna
show up early and practice and spend
five minutes working on this yeah each
guy had something different that they're
going to do but if you have a whole team
that has their commitments written down
then you start to see them better and I
want to do this with teams too I say
okay we all talk about being a great
teammate but let's talk about what great
teammates do and we'd put them up on the
board and you have all these things that
make a great teammate and then you ask
each person to pick one they're going to
focus on in the course of the season I
think you also have to get at the why
like why is that your goal right why is
that personally important to you and I
think that that gets to the connectivity
piece like you got to get you know
beneath everybody's skin and find out
what makes them tick what's important to
them and why it's important to them what
is the drive why is it important to you
that you get this many yards or you know
win the Super Bowl and and if you can
connect with that then I think you you
can you can like create you know a way
to support that as a leader or as coach
love that like knowing your why because
we don't get burned out because of what
we do we get burned out because we
forget why we do it so I think you
nailed it when the Y all we should drive
everything you do like I have the team
sometimes picked a word for the year so
each player picks a word that's going to
drive them to be their best but then we
ask why did you pick that word and
what's the why behind the word because
is the meaning behind the word is even
more powerful in the word itself hmm and
where to service come into that well if
some people's word might be service you
know for me serve was my word one year
but services only picked like a word
every year yeah yeah every year kind of
work your somatic we're doing it for six
years wrote a book one word that will
change your life with Dan and Jimmy
they've been doing this for over twenty
years together
they're like accountability partners
great buddies they've been doing it for
years and they have a thing one word and
so I started doing it when they told me
the idea six years ago and it was
catalytic it was so pal so one of your
words man over the years so they have
been purpose was my first word serve was
a word another year rise was my word
another year I want to rise to a new
level of health I was dealing with a lot
of food challenges I'm a lot of food
allergies so I eat mostly vegan except
seafood so I do seafood and vegan my
word was forgive last year which was
tough that was a tough year because I
had to forgive my biological father so I
worked on that this year I would is
still to be still and - that's a tough
one not be drawn to all the craziness
and the noise yeah I'm not doing great
with it this year I have to admit it's
not for next year sale I know you not
allowed to argue about you nailed re
just you know what it's not meant to be
a word where I failed or I didn't
succeed with my word it's a word that's
meant to mold you and shape you and it's
just part of the journey but next year
there's a new word that's meant for you
so every year there's a word that's
meant through and I can look back and
see how these words have shaved my life
you know it was praying one year and my
wife was persevere so she had persevere
I had pregs we have teenagers so he said
somehow we'll get through this huh
that's funny
what would you tell your your young self
your twenty-three year old self you know
what have you learned over the course of
this adventure that you've been on I
took student athletes this all the time
in college
say the one thing I would tell myself is
don't worry she's out there you'll find
her in terms of beating my wife so
everyone's searching for love like their
yogi like worry about that
like they worry about meeting the minute
they're meant to be with yeah and they
do worry about that so I would that
would one thing I would tell myself the
other thing I would tell myself is what
I've learned from dr. James gills I've
shared this before in other places but
it's so powerful being an ultra athlete
like you are dr. James gills is the only
person the planet I believe who has
completed six double Ironman triathlons
six Doublemint is the only person still
or I don't know what's his name dr.
James gills yeah I don't know maybe
double Iron Man huh last time he did
though is 59 years old
uh-huh 59 awesome yeah and he was asked
how he did it and he said I've learned
to talk to myself instead of listen to
myself he said I listen to myself I know
of a negative all the fear all the doubt
all the complaints but if I talk to
myself I could feed myself with the
words and the encouragement that I need
to keep on moving forward and just
because we have a negative thought it
doesn't mean we have to believe it so I
think that's one of the biggest
challenge we face as athletes as people
as human beings is that when those
negative thoughts come in we believe the
lie that those negative thoughts tell
because we're failing to draw the
distinction between the thinking mind
and the higher self right you have to be
come the observer of your thoughts and
once you can bifurcate and you go oh
yeah my brain is telling me this but
like I actually have a choice just
because it's saying that I don't have to
self identify with that and where do
those negative thoughts come from it
could be you know because your dad left
here when you were one I mean you know
you can go down the rabbit hole without
forever the day of thoughts of spiritual
those negative thoughts I've had a lot
of conversations with a good good
friends who you know are spiritual
people they're not religious but weak I
say where do those negative thoughts
come from they should be intellect I go
what's the intellect where those
negative thoughts coming from they come
from consciousness and the duality of
consciousness is there is love and
there's hate there is good there's bad
there's at the highest level there's
just one this put at duality and our
duality level
there is fear and that fear fears a liar
the negative thoughts are lies and the
more you can tell people observe those
thoughts and see them for what they are
and don't buy into them and don't
believe them then you can move forward
you can speak the truth feed the
positive and move forward that's what I
would tell myself in the past how do you
get people to to come to that
realization now I mean what are the
practices you have people starting to
like inventory and journal or the
tactics the key is first awareness I
used first teaching this like sharing
this with people is so important it's
one of the things I've shared with a lot
of professional athletes this year so
this is one of the key messages I was
sharing and it's like wow it really hits
them like yeah this thing I don't have
to believe them like yeah that won't
come from me because the minute you
realize they're not coming from like you
you stop blaming yourself and you
realize that it's a spiritual battle and
you don't have to believe the lie you
could just continue to move forward so I
think first and foremost but what you
can do is write down I heard on my
previous podcast he entered his jewel
the singer and that's great that was a
great one and she said it was so great
because I had been talking to mazey
incredible and she said she writes down
her lives
she writes that her lives on Lynch the
left side of the paper she waits on the
lies on the right side she writes down
the truth to those lies and I think we
can all do that yeah I think it comes
down to taking control of the story you
tell yourself about yourself there's
something I've talked about on the
podcast many times but we string
together this narrative that's you know
rooted in things that have happened to
us or things that we you know claim to
be true that aren't necessarily true and
then we live out that reality and when
you when you start to write it down you
can go wait a minute like I don't have
to define myself by this or maybe this
isn't even true and I have the power to
we you know recalibrate that narrative
until a different story about myself I
love that Donald Miller wrote a book
called a million miles and a thousand
years it's one of my favorite books a
million miles around you're so
incredible and it's about the fact that
our life is like a movie and every main
character to move
we wants to achieve something but in
order to achieve something what they
must overcome some sort of conflict some
sort of adversity it's the main central
thing to any great movie and so must way
and so the story you tell yourself as
you go through the conflict as you go
through the adversity ultimately defines
whether you continue to move forward to
reach it so are we the victim or with a
hero is our movie and inspirational town
or is it a drama or a horror story and I
think ultimately we the more we define
our life as an inspirational tale the
more we see ourselves as a hero not the
victim we get up and we move forward
victims get knocked down but what
happens they stay down and they complain
but heroes get knocked down like a
victim but didn't get back up and
through adversity through the conflict
they don't they create the future I like
that mountains beautiful well we got a
UH we got to bring this energy bus back
here but a little as a bit of journey
yeah now is get it's been awesome but I
always like to leave people with you
know a little bit of wisdom or
inspiration you know for the person
who's listening who just you just feel
stuck you know they're just they can't
see their way out of their current
situation which maybe isn't terrible but
ain't that great either like they're not
living their best most authentic life
and and and they can't see where the
exit hatch is and these need that first
step or you know a little bit of
guidance to kind of broaden their
perspective and perhaps you know open up
the the possibility for a better
trajectory I think the best thing we
could always share is truth in
perspective and principle rather than
say do this this and this because
actually to be different for each person
based on consciousness and based on
what's meant for that person but I
always talk about the fact that we will
all be pruned if you go through life you
realize that you will be pruned like a
tree and if you ever seen a tree that's
been pruned it looks like it's been
destroyed but it hasn't been destroyed
the pruning is meant to help the tree
grow more fully and just like that tree
we get pruned and it looks like we've
been destroyed but know that
circumstance that
and that challenge that setback is not
meant to destroy you it's meant to help
you grow more fully and your perspective
your mindset during the pruning during
the challenge ultimately determines
whether you will continue to keep on
growing to become all that you're meant
to be and to become more fully so just
be aware of that pruning that it's part
of the growth process I believe this
four stages to greatness the preparation
stage the the growth stage well the
plant ectasia before the growth stage
planting growth and then the harvest and
so you have to go through the growth
stage to harvest you have to go through
the pruning to go through the harvest
and it's going to be all part of your
journey right and not be in a rush to
just get to the harvest right and to
know that that there are stages in life
that you have to go through and it
doesn't mean it's the end don't say it's
the end it's just a new beginning
so perspective and mindset hopefully
that leads you then to an action that
you will take to better yourself and
improve yourself whether it's a
gratitude walk thank you walk whether
it's journaling whether it's going for a
run and starting to do more exercise
getting yourself fit for each person
it's going to be different but
ultimately it's about becoming the best
version of you but ultimately you have
to know that this is just part of your
growth process and part of your journey
and everyone wants to go through it no
one goes through life unpruned yeah I
like that I think you know for a lot of
people they feel bad about themselves
because they don't know what they're
passionate about or they don't feel like
they have this sort of purposeful
direction and they shame themselves yes
and I think it's okay to not know that I
think it's important for people to
understand that you have permission to
not know that you are in that you know
you're in that pruning stage you're in
this gestation period and you're
supposed to be contemplating this and
wrestling with it and and trust that you
know ultimately if you devote yourself
to that process that you will ultimately
figure it out and then emerge into that
growth phase that precedes the harvest
and start to just live on purpose you
may not know what your bigger purpose is
but I
the more you start to live with purpose
and we have on purpose and be
intentional a greater purpose custom
photo video so I I call your small I
like your small I like okay I'm just
gonna make a difference here I'm over
the coffee shop and I'm going to impact
that person the coffee shop today I want
to make that person smile
I'm going to get on that bus I'm going
to see how many people I can interact
with on the bus today and just make them
laugh or maybe you're an introvert okay
this is all extroverted thing but maybe
you're an introvert and I'm going to
write something today that's going to
make a difference and I'm going to send
it to someone so start living with
intention on purpose and I find that the
more you do that this bigger purpose
that we're talking about starts to flow
through you it's almost like the
pipeline opens up and the bigger purpose
starts to flow to you once you start
living on purpose yeah that's true yeah
that's a good way to I think we parked
the bus all right all right gonna ride
thank you yeah great on me John Tate I
really appreciate it
awesome man keep doing what you're doing
two books a year timeless if you go you
look at 35 books if someone's listening
wait you know what's that will what's
the first book that they if they're if
you know if you're new to the listener
where do you suggest people I always say
discovery the energy of energy buzz yeah
that's you know your best self that's
still the best
that's know until boys all my books
combined a really yeah yeah and I would
just say start they're all about
positive energy and they can visit me at
johngraden.com
jo-ann Gordon calm yeah and you're on
you're on Twitter you're pretty active
on Twitter right yeah look buddy right
there
love to tweet sometimes a little too
much but did you like that to share
positive messages I mean a lot of ideas
will just come to me and I tweet him out
uh-huh
and you are you you have any speaking
gigs coming up or if I didn't hold her
up on your site no or is that all
private you ever do like open to the
public some some events where they'll
have they'll have the events I don't put
on my own events but I'll speak at
public events but I'm going to the
horticulture Association of America
speaking in Columbus Ohio and then I
yeah coming back from there I'm going to
do the Rams on the 30th of July so
looking forward to speaking to that team
and then hopefully do some public events
in the fall awesome now say
best of luck oh thank you thank you back
you that talk to me again sometime
alright yeah how we got to talk about
our diets yeah we should yeah that would
ya that's to me that's that's
fascinating it's something that I think
people need to eat healthier in this
world and what you're doing is so
important I mean it's it's it's it's
what's excites me most about your work I
mean are you do an incredible work
you're so insightful on so many things
like Wow
but but but this is our body is our
temple yeah it is it's true and I'm sure
you see this I mean you mentioned it
earlier when you go and you visit these
professional athletes a lot of them are
just not eating that well man and it's
crazy
these guys are Ferraris and they're
putting you know junk in the trunk
I feel like 10 20 years from them we're
going to actually realize that a lot of
injuries are the result of the food's no
question about that they're eating I
would love someone to be able to do a
study to figure out like pulled muscles
I guarantee are the results of different
foods and food allergies that people are
allergic to yeah I don't doubt it
alright well come back a whole food
awesome run thanks right see we did it
yeah all right I feel good I feel good
all right cool great Iron Man peace
laughs thank you thank you
cool thank you so much Harry
all right we did a great conversation I
hope you guys got a lot out of that I
certainly did it was a joy being able to
connect with John in person and share
his powerful message with you guys today
one pretty wild thing something I
thought would be worth mentioning is
that after we wrapped the podcast and I
was just sort of chatting with John as I
was packing up all my gear I discovered
that George Boyardee the young Cornell
lacrosse player who unfortunately
perished that we discussed in the
conversation and that is the subject of
John's book the hard hat actually went
to my high school land in school in
Bethesda Maryland which is sort of a
perennial lacrosse powerhouse so it
seems my path with John is even more
intertwined than I originally realized
kind of an amazing bizarre coincidence
in any of that there's a foundation set
up in George's name so if you want to
learn more about George and his story
and the work that the foundation is
doing in his honor you can check that
out at Boyardee foundation org it's B oh
I R di foundation.org and of course for
more on John go to John Gordon com
jo-anne Gordon com no H in the John he's
also at John Gordon 11:00 on Twitter and
on Instagram and you can find them on
Facebook all those places give a shout
out let him know what you thought of the
podcast say hey what's up look I keep
saying this but my mission in life if I
have to repeat myself again
is to help you guys experience your
version of what I have experienced
eating and living the way that I do
everything I do from the books to the
podcasts the public speaking to the
retreats the travel all my athletic
endeavors everything is sort of designed
and oriented around advancing this
purpose of advocating a healthy
lifestyle and intellectually you get it
it's easy to understand intellectually
and yet so many still struggle with how
to implement a more plant-based plant
centric lifestyle how do you get these
plants on your plate what exactly do I
eat how do I begin what if I don't like
this or that what if I'm allergic to
nuts or can I buy this stuff I'm not a
cook I don't know what to do in the
kitchen it's for all these reasons that
we created the plant power meal planner
which is this unbelievably powerful
robust online mobile friendly resource
tool that takes all the mystery and
guesswork out of a whole affair at an
incredibly affordable
dollar ninety per week let's face it
that's like loose change
that's barely a cup of coffee at
Starbucks in exchange here's what you
get thousands of plant-based recipes
thousands unlimited meal plans a grocery
list everything totally personalize and
customize and individuated based on your
goals and your food preferences and your
allergies and your time constraints
amazing customer support from a team of
experts grocery delivery in 22
metropolitan areas by instacart so in
essence you join this meal planner you
fill out all this incredibly powerful
detailed information about yourself
like I mentioned you're then delivered
all of these recipes you can make meal
plans out of it you can make grocery
lists and it's all integrated with
instacart so if you live in one of these
cities you can get all the groceries
that you need to make these recipes
delivered right to your door it's just
insane we're getting amazing feedback
everybody who is signed up is absolutely
loving it it's really life
transformative and essentially if you
want to make a powerful lifestyle change
with sticking power you have to make the
healthy choice the convenient choice and
that's what this is all about it's about
making healthy choices more convenient
for you guys so if you want to check it
out go to meals rich roll calm or click
on meal planner on the top menu and rich
roll calm and you'll find all the
information there that you need if you
would like to support this show in my
work there's a couple ways to do it to
share it with your friends and on social
media leave a review on iTunes hit that
subscribe button that's big make sure
your friends subscribe
that's huge too we also have a patreon
set up for people who want to
financially support my work and thank
you to everybody who has made that
effort quite incredible and I greatly
greatly appreciate it every week I send
out a free weekly short email it's
called roll call packed with tips and
tools and resources things I've come
across over the course of the week
usually a bunch of articles I read a
documentary I watched a new product that
I'm enjoying just useful stuff
no spam I'm not trying to make any money
off this there's no affiliate links in
it I don't profit from it at all I did
take a three week break but I did some
one out yesterday so I'm back on the
game if this sounds interesting to you
again it's totally free
original calm and just enter your email
address some of those email capture
windows that comes up and when you're on
my website you can also check out the
shop where we all have all kinds of like
cool swag and merch we got signed copies
of all our books finding ultra the plant
power way this cheetahs nuts
we got cool t-shirts and sticker packs
and just fun stuff also I want to talk
about the spring I keep doing this but I
think it's really important my podcast
conversation with Scott Harrison from
charity:water was really impactful on me
personally and I know it was for a lot
of you guys who are listening and my
call to action in the wake of that was
to encourage all of you to join their
monthly subscription service called the
spring 100% of all monies received as a
result of a monthly donation that you
make goes entirely 100 percent towards
providing clean water for people that
don't have access to it as a result of
this call to action we have now enlisted
the support of the RRP community to the
tune of four wells per year you guys
have contributed to four wells per year
and my company is now chipping in by
building an additional well every single
year that's our commitment so that's
five wells this year alone but I think
we can make it 10 I really want to make
it 10 and I think that's a very doable
goal because most of you have an extra
20 bucks or 30 bucks a month that you
can donate for such an extraordinary
life-changing payoff so I want you to
really think about the impact that you
can have and how amazing it will feel to
you to make that impact so make a
donation to charity water via the spring
their monthly subscription service to
learn more go to this very specific URL
it's important that you use this so they
can track and know that you guys are
coming to them through this podcast
here's what it is ce WT r dot org
forward slash rich roll spring
CW TR org forward slash rich roll spring
which also I'll put that up in the show
notes and there's a banner on the
episode page for this episode too so you
can click through that I want to thank
today's sponsors Harry's superior shave
at an affordable price
friends of the ritual podcast can visit
Harry's Kampf or SS roll to redeem your
free trial set
which comes with a razor five blade
cartridge shading gel and post shave gel
all you pay is just the shipping and
health IQ life insurance design for the
active and health-conscious never
overpay again never ever ever to learn
more and get a free quote go to health
IQ com4 slash roll and finally I want to
thank everybody who worked tirelessly
I'll put this episode on Jason camula
for audio engineering and production he
also compiled the show notes and helps
get the WordPress page configured he
does a lot of work behind the scenes
Shawn Patterson for help on graphics all
the cool motion graphics that you see
anything involving fonts and typeface
and images that Shawn he does a great
job and theme music as always by
analemma thanks for the love you guys
see you soon peace and class
[Music]